hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
iqcp is a four-letter word presented by
dr. Steven cotton we're excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lakor's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning for more information please go
to www.hsn the Jo love lab words and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
before we thinking I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window for use the Q&A
button to let us know you're having a
problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please sleep on the CTE button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. Steven cotton dr.
cotton is director for chemistry in your
knowledge a toxicology and point-of-care
testing at the Ohio State University
Wexner Medical Center an assistant
professor in pathology at The Ohio State
University he received his PhD in
pharmaceutical sciences from the School
of Pharmacy at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel Hill where he also
completed his training in clinical
chemistry in the Department of Pathology
dr. cotton is board-certified in
clinical chemistry by the American Board
of clinical clinical chemistry
he's also served as the chair of the
ATCC Ohio Valley local section and is
currently the newsletter editor and
online community moderator for the new
mass spectometry and separation sciences
and this three division of the American
Association for clinical chemistry his
primary research interests include drug
testing in alternative matrices and
operational efficiency metrics for
clinical laboratories please join me in
welcoming dr. Stephen cotton I will now
turn the presentation over to him thank
you for that wonderful introduction so
today we're gonna talk about iqcp and
its impact on laboratories so what does
iqcp mean to you this has been a topic
that is provided a lot of stress for
laboratories and there's been some
creative acronyms associated with this
one of them is idiots questioning
competent professionals I question
confusing policies indiscriminate
quagmire creating panic I quit
clinical pathology or imposed quality
control plan but most of you probably
know that it stands for individualized
quality control plans so just an outline
of what we're going to cover we're first
going to begin conventional approaches
to quality control in the lab and then
we're going to discuss CMS changes to
quality control what that means for the
affected tests and then how to perform
an IQ CP and then finally end with what
does the College of American
Pathologists a about iqcp what is in
their checklist so a little bit of
background guidance for quality control
for clinical laboratories has
conventionally stated two things
it is said that two levels of external
quality control must be performed every
24 hours or you must follow the
manufacturer's instructions for quality
control however this can create some
conflicts if the manufacturers do not
recommend external controls at the same
frequency of every 24 hours and so this
discrepancy has largely gone unenforced
as there are many tests and many
instrument platforms which are
moderately are highly complex that
actually don't meet these clear
requirements an effective January 1st
2016
if labs wished to remain compliance the
practice of running QC less frequently
they must perform in iqcp and so the
iqcp involves three things it involves a
risk assessment a quality control plan
and a quality assessment now labs have
shared a lot of frustrations regarding
about this because this concept of iqcp
is relatively abstract and it's
relatively new and so a lot of laughs
have simply said we'll just I wish I
could understand this better just tell
me what I need to do don't make me think
about something how can a small hospital
with limited resources perform the
appropriate studies needed to implement
an IQ see there was been very few very
little training and the instructions
have been very confusing the amount of
work required is often very daunting and
the guidance is vague and abstract so
it's very frustrating for something so
important with such poorly defined
expectations and probably most
importantly labs have said we haven't
had enough time to do this so let's go
into some of the things that CMS has
changed about quality control the
initial notification that there was
going to be a change to quality control
starts in 2011 this is where the initial
notification that
EQC or equivalent quality control would
be phased out and then replaced with a
lab specific risk-based QC approach
flash-forward two years
CMS releases a bulletin better
describing these QC changes they discuss
iqcp training and the transition process
that will be effective January 1st 2016
and will be phased in during a two-year
period at that point there will be no
more EQC equivalent QC or electronic you
see that will be valid so what is iqcp
mean for you it may be impractical to
run two levels of external QC every day
for your test this can be due to just
cost restraints too many instruments the
methodology the assay doesn't really
limit itself to running to external
levels you might batch per cartridge or
per kit or per specimen or there could
be just a lack of control material and
so iqcp gives labs the flexibility to
meet these regulatory QC requirements
that are appropriate for your test
system your patient population and your
test environment it's important to note
that iqcp is technically voluntary but
the implementation is needed if you run
less than two levels of external control
every day of patient testing some of
these sub specialties that have been
excluded from iqcp include anatomic
pathology histopathology
oral pathology and cytology there are
also some interesting nuances with tests
with multiple sub specialties so under
CLIA certain tests may be assigned one
of several sub specialties
the test is eligible for an iqcp based
on any of the subspecialties then the
laboratory may elect to use an IQ CP
approach the bat test regardless of the
subspecialty they have assigned to it in
their laboratory for example fish
testing may be classified as either
histopathology or cytogenetics and so
the lab may have it under histopathology
on their CLIA certificate if so the lab
can still use an IQ CP for their fish
testing so what are some of the
responsibilities of the CLIA lab
director first and foremost the director
is responsible for accurate and reliable
test results that are appropriate for
patient care no matter what QC method or
approach is is used they are also
responsible for ensuring that the iqcp
meets the requirements set forth in the
iqcp interpretive guidelines they are
also responsible for signing and dating
the iqcp this cannot be delegated so now
that we've reviewed the CMS changes to
QC let's talk about the affected some of
the affected tests what tests might be
included in this iqcp program a lot of
these are actually point-of-care tests
some tests that currently use electronic
quality control methods like eye stats
microbiology testing blood gases
moderately complex kid testing a CT or
clotting and anywhere where manufacturer
QC is less stringent than clear
requirements so I've broken that down
into a little more detail here for blood
gas instruments internal or electronic
QC is most often used and these
instruments can be deployed throughout
the hospital they can be a part of
respiratory therapy which has multiple
sites throughout the hospital but they
can also be found in operating rooms and
the ed4 microbiology testing
ability testing on the Microscan gene
expert testing proceedeth and
commercially prepared media may not
actually have two levels of external
control run daily in addition you can
have rapid molecular tests for flu serum
specimens on point of care HCG kits and
pointer fear on testing or TV what test
is iqcp not include this is not a
comprehensive list it is the
responsibility of the laboratory to
audit all of their tests to see if they
currently meet the criteria of two
levels of external QC every day of
patient testing and we'll talk more
about this later so we're gonna go into
the meat of the presentation how do we
actually perform an IQ CP well CMS has
provided an iqcp workbook it is
available for download online at WWDC
and it outlines the steps involved to
develop an IQ CP that meets the
requirements set forth by CMS the iqcp
or individualized quality control plan
has three major components it is
composed of a risk assessment that looks
at what can go wrong with this
particular test system that is the
starting point of the iqcp once you've
performed the risk assessment and
identified the risks involved with that
testing you can develop a quality
control plan so how do we prevent or
detect errors from happening for the
risks that we've identified and then the
third step is a quality assessment is
the quality control plan that we've put
in place effective
we're actually identifying and
preventing errors in our test system our
labs are probably already addressing
some if not most of these things in our
qi and QM programs so the iqcp is really
just a formal process
of collating all of your efforts
together in a single cohesive plan let's
begin with the risk assessment so the
first part of the risk assessment is to
really look at the total testing process
there are three stages and five areas
that are required for laboratories to
evaluate the three stages are the pre
analytical phase the analytical phase
and the post analytical phase for the
five areas they can be divided into
those three stages these these include
looking at the specimen the test system
the reagents the environment and the
testing personnel by looking at the
three stages and the five areas together
you evaluate the total testing process
to look at the risks associated with
that test or test system so some of the
five required areas if we look at some
areas related to the specimen are there
specifics related to patient preparation
are there issues with specimen
collection and labeling are there issues
with specimen storage and stability and
transport are there specifics related to
processing that can affect the outcome
for the test system are there adequate
systems in place to identify spotted
specimens to look at calibration issues
mechanical failure optical failure or
built in procedural or electronic
controls that give you information about
the performance of the test system
additionally what about the reagents do
you look do you need to look at shipping
and receiving storage conditions
preparation or expiration of the
reagents and then the environment are
there temperature humidity requirements
altitude or dust requirements that may
impact the accuracy of your test system
and finally lab should evaluate their
testing personnel do they need specific
training do they need regular competency
are there unique
educational requirements and experience
needed and staffing do you have a high
turnover of staff in certain areas that
may impact their training and competency
over other areas CMS has provided a
worksheet to evaluate this risk
assessment in these five areas and so
what's shown here are the pre analytical
analytical and post analytical phases
going across the top followed by the
five stages specimen test system reagent
environment and testing personnel a good
way to evaluate the consequence of your
risk is a risk hazard matrix this is
actually not specific to iqcp but it can
be used to classify the degree of risk
that you may have identified and the two
areas that you want to look at are the
likelihood then that an event will
happen versus the potential consequence
that an event will happen so if the
likelihood is high that you will have a
very severe event that would be
considered a high risk error but if you
have a very low likelihood that an event
will occur and if it does the potential
consequences low that would be
categorized as a low risk event so let's
walk through a blood gas example here so
let's say we've identified for the
specimen we can cut we can have issues
of mislabeled specimens and we can have
issues of clots can we put a system in
place that can detect and identify this
yes well we could implement barcode
scanning and we have a standard
operating procedure for the collection
that clearly identifies labeling of the
specimen for this test system if
calibration is expired does that impact
there is the results yes
well can we have a system in place that
identifies that yes the instrument has
automatic lockout and autumn
calibration for the reagent what is the
impact of a degraded reagent to impact
your results can we identify this yes we
can use QC whether its internal or
external QC to evaluate the stability of
the reagent and let's say your test
system is impacted by excess humidity do
we have an ability to detect excess
humidity and prevent it yes we can keep
a daily log of the humidity levels in
the lab and then recognize when the
humidity requirements are not met for
that test system and for the testing
personnel if you have inexperienced
technologists would that impact the
results yes can you do something to
mitigate that risk we can implement
training and competency and even have
them review the iqcp risk assessment
that we've done for that test system and
then we can go back and classify the
likelihood or the risk hazard for each
individual risk that we've identified
and I've given some just examples here
that maybe we think that the specimens
are medium the expired calibration is
very low due to the lockout the reagent
is medium the environment might be high
maybe we have a high issue a big issue
with humidity in our lab and then
inexperienced technologist would be low
because we're confident in our training
and competency the historical data can
actually be used to classify the risk
and justify their classification so it's
important for labs to go back and review
their own historical data so using
historical data the eye and iqcp your
own laboratory data is the support for
your risk assessment and your QC plan
you can look at the number of
instruments the number of instruments
that have sent back for repairs over the
last two years the number of failed PT
specimens with discrepant reports the
number of event reports or service
occurrences that have included
that particular instrument or platform
the number of personnel in the turnover
of personnel each year the number of
rejected specimens and their reason for
rejection over the last year the number
of corrected reports or your own
internal QC data so now that we've
identified the risk and we've classified
them based on importance we can now
design a quality control plan that meets
the risks let's say the medium and high
risk and creates a system to mitigate or
identify those particular errors as I
said before once you complete the risk
assessment you need to determine which
risks need to be monitored or controlled
or have they already been addressed by
the manufacturer the quality control
plan must is designed must incorporate
all the possible QC procedures not just
traditional to see the number of the QC
plan must include the following items
the number of QC
the type of QC the frequency and the
acceptable criteria your QC plan can
incorporate many different types of QC
this can be electronic controls
equipment maintenance logs internal
controls personnel training and
competency assessment calibration data
proficiency testing or other data
specific to the test platform there is
no minimum frequency however no QC is
unacceptable and QC cannot be less than
the manufacturers recommendation and the
QC frequency that you propose must be
must be supported by your risk
assessment so let's go back to the risk
that we buy dead identified in our
example from our risk assessment we
thought we had an issue with mislabeled
specimens plots the type of quality
control we want to implement as
verification of the specimen label and
verification of the specimen quality we
want to do this with each specimen and
then how are we going to track this and
what have we accepted
criteria we're gonna refer to our
specimen collection policy and we're
gonna track all of our rejected
specimens in the instance of a degraded
reagent the type of quality control that
we're going to use is an internal
quality control and this is going to be
two levels every eight hours according
to the manufacturer and the results must
be within the manufacturers range and
these results must be documented so for
our other risk of excess humidity that
we've identified we're gonna perform
temperature and humidity checks in the
lab and this is going to be gun this is
going to be performed daily and are
acceptable criteria according to the
manufacturer it's going to be 30 to 80
percent so we've taken the risk we've
developed a quality control plan and now
we're going to use the quality
assessment to take all of the QC
measures that we've established and
we're gonna create a system to review
and detect and improve the quality
control plan let's take a moment and
contrast quality control versus quality
assessment if quality control means
recording temperatures quality
assessment means the review of the
temperature logs if quality control
means documenting your QC results then
the quality assessment means reviewing
QC results monthly or even daily if your
quality control is documenting personnel
training then your quality assessment
would be reviewing and auditing your
your employee training records
furthermore document maintenance would
be reviewing maintenance and documenting
competency would be reviewing and
auditing your personnel files so some of
the documents that you may want to
consider and this is from CMS regarding
their iqcp workbook may include QC data
sheets Delta check logs proficiency
testing results complaints or event
reports from
specimen collection logs specimen
rejection logs critical values or panic
values turnaround time reports
temperature logs maintenance logs
training logs and FDA alerts and so the
quality assessment takes all of your QC
measures that you've established and you
want to create a system to
systematically on a regular basis review
and detect and improve the quality plan
that you've put in place so here's an
example of a quality assessment so the
QA activity would be supervisor review
and instrument pronounced that are
reviewed and QC logs that's done on a
monthly basis and the assessment was
their variation if there was yes then
you propose a corrective action so in
this case for the corrective action they
listed remedial training of testing
personnel and then reassess the testing
personnel performance their second QA
monitor would be accompany assessment
this is done on an annual basis after
the first year if there was no variation
then you don't need to rewrite or review
the assessment if the QA monitor is the
laboratory director reviews and signs
the QC logs if this is done quarterly
and there's no variation from the
established policy then you don't need
to provide a corrective action so what
are some of the iqcp resources and
templates that you can use you can use
the templates provided by CMS which are
available on online however many
manufacturers have actually created
templates and platforms for assays that
are affected by iqcp this primarily
evaluates the risk assessment portion of
the iqcp and labs will still need to
individualize the plan based on their
specific needs I would encourage you to
reach out to your vendor for your
support
I've listed two examples of companies
blood-gas that are affected by iqcp both
of which have created iqcp templates
which can be used by laboratories
additionally the American Society of
microbiology has created PowerPoint
templates and PDF templates for iqcp
plans for commercial m.i.c antimicrobial
susceptibility testing because this is a
test system that is affected by iqcp so
now we're going to look at what CA P
says in their new checklist regarding
CMS proposed changes to iqcp so what
does cap say about iqcp there are
currently two important documents on
CAPS website there is a flowchart for
determination of eligibility to use an
iqcp
and there is also a new iqcp cap
checklist item and forms
the flow chart the flow chart determines
whether an iqcp can be used based on the
testing weights or non wave status the
pathology subspecialty the manufacturers
recommendation for QC frequency and some
information regarding microbiology
testing
let's look individually now at the cap
checklist items there are five checklist
items that were reviewed and approved by
CMS in August of 2015 the five checklist
items specifically deal with iqcp and
there are two iqcp related forms the
first one is that laboratories must now
have and maintain an iqcp list so the
laboratory has identified all the tests
that they have implemented in iqcp plan
and completed the cap forms the
laboratories using individualized
quality control plans
this is very similar to the laboratory
developed tests list that all
laboratories must now have and maintain
as well checklist item sir form one is
the list of iqcp this is the list of
individualized quality control plans and
so you can see that they the cap is
asking for three specific things they're
asking for the laboratory section or
department that the iqcp a lives the
test instrument and device this includes
the name of the instrument the
manufacturer and the model and then the
tests are specific analytes that are
included in this iqcp so for instance
for a blood gas analyzer one instrument
may actually have multiple analytes that
are impacted by iqcp
and these can be found on caps website
on a lab solution suite accreditation
forms and instructions the second thing
is an iqcp summary form and so this is
very similar to the form provided by CMS
but cap has customized it a little bit
for the two for the inspection process
and so you can see it has the instrument
device including the name and
manufacturer and model the test effected
the number of devices in use at that
CLIA site and the number of test sites
if there are more than one sites at a
particular CLIA number and then you may
recognize the five areas that were
required in the risk assessment and so
the bottom has you list all of the
processes that you've identified as
being risks during your risk assessment
and these deal with reagents environment
specimen test system testing personnel
and they've included an other category
as well so checklist item number two
actually details a little bit more about
the risk
assessment so it first says that the
iqcp for a test device an instrument
includes a risk assessment to evaluate
the potential sources of error to
include all of the following and I've
highlighted three things that are
actually additional items relative to
what is listed in the CMS document the
first thing is the intended medical use
of the test system and impact if
inaccurate results are reported or
clinical risk and so if you remember
when we talked about classifying risks
as low medium or high this is where cap
wants you to actually evaluate the
clinical risk and this is not detailed
in the CMS regulations for iqcp
the other thing that is unique to cap is
the data from the laboratories own
environment instrument equipment
performance and testing personnel must
be used in the risk assessment so they
are really stressing that laboratories
use their own data to go back and look
at historical data to evaluate these
risks and then the final thing is that
the manufacturer's instructions and
recommendations are actually included in
the risk assessment so if the
manufacturer lists a specific item that
can greatly impact the analytical
performance of a test system you need to
really look at that in your risk
assessment and make sure that that is
addressed in your quality control plan
so the third new cap checklist item for
i4ii QC B is the quality control plan
approval so in addition to writing a
quality control plan the iqcp has to be
approved by the laboratory director
prior to implementation and it's
important to note that this is not it
cannot be delegated to a designate it
has to be approved by the laboratory
director
so checklist item number four the
elements of the quality control plan so
many of these mimic what is outlined in
the CMS guidelines for the quality
control plan so you must monitor aspects
based on the risk assessment that
detailed the number and the type of QC
and the frequency of the quality control
that you're going to use the criteria
for it's acceptable performance how are
you're going to monitor the test and
environment and the reagents the
specimen quality instrument calibration
training a competency but the one thing
that is actually unique to the cap
checklist item is that they want a
provision for dealing with multiple
identical devices or variations used
under one iqcp so you can't just monitor
a single blood gas analyzer if you have
11 in your respiratory therapy
department so you have to have a system
that actually evaluates these multiple
identical devices the other item that is
of note is that external material
control material must be analyzed at
least every 31 days and with new Lots
and shipments of reagents or more
frequently if indicated in the
manufacturer's instructions so even if
the manufacturer does not suggest that
you need to run QC every 31 days cap is
outlined that external control material
must be analyzed every 31 days and so
it's important again to make sure that
you've addressed multiple identical
devices so we'll talk about that a
little bit more and the nuances there so
there's a couple of different scenarios
let's say you have the same instrument
at the same CLIA site under the under
the same CLIA site at multiple locations
you can have one iqcp per test system or
CLIA site but the quality control plan
must monitor all in
at your Clea site you can have the same
instrument at multiple Clea sites within
a health care system in this case
multiple IQ CPS are needed for each Clea
site portions of the risk assessment may
be shared but each laboratories
individual data must be used and each
CLIA director must sign their respective
I can see a plan let's say you have
multiple analytes on a single instrument
one iqcp per test system the risk
assessment must address the test system
and each individually and they let's say
you have the same analyte on multiple
instruments in this case you would need
a separate iqcp for each test system or
instrument that is a unique manufacturer
model so the new checklist item number
five relates to the quality assessment
the majority of the things outlined in
the cap checklist are actually mirrors
of what CMS says the one thing that I
want to point out here is that cap has
added that reappraisal of the quality
control plan by the laboratory director
or designate is done at least annually
so this is not included in the CMS
guidelines for iqcp but it is included
in the CA P guidelines so just to
compare and contrast what CMS has
mandated about iqcp versus what cap is
added for the risk assessment CMS and
CLIA said you must look at the specimen
the test system the reagent environment
and personnel cap has added that you
need to evaluate the clinical risk you
need to include your laboratory data and
you need to also make sure you've looked
at the manufacturer's instructions for
the quality control plan CMS and CLIA
has said you must explicitly define the
number the type the Freak
see an acceptable criteria for you for
your QC and cap is at it that you need
to make sure you have provisions from
multiple devices on one iqcp plan for
the quality assessment CMS has simply
said that you need to review the QC data
that you have set forth in your Houston
plan and Kappas added that you need to
reappear QC plan annually by the
laboratory director or designee and you
need a list of all i q CP tests at a
specific CLIA site and so the things
listed on the right-hand column again
are just additional cap components that
are not included in the CMS regulations
so how do we put it all together just to
recap we begin with a risk assessment
and we want to look at our three
analytical analytical and post
analytical phases we do that by looking
at five different areas including the
specimen type the operator the reagents
the environment and the test system your
gonna identify some risks from that risk
assessment and you're gonna draw from
your historical data and analyte and
location specific risks for your CLIA or
laboratory site and then you're gonna
take the risk that you've identified and
you're gonna find a way to control those
particular risks so let's say we've
identified fifteen risks we might be
able to control or identify those risks
with five types of quality control and
those are going to be put together into
a quality control plan so what's and now
moving from the quality control plan to
the quality assessment we have our five
controls and for the quality assessment
for cap they want to make sure that you
review the quality control and
instrument equipment and maintenance and
function data they want you to evaluate
pre analytic analytic and post analytic
errors and they also want to make sure
that you evaluate complaints from
clinicians and other health care
providers related to the
testing you want to make sure that this
data is reviewed monthly that you have
some corrective action if you find
deviation and that the quality control
plan is reappeared annually by the
director so what are the benefits of
iqcp well is there a financial incentive
you could make an argument that there's
actually a large cost avoidance by doing
an IQ CP if you were to predict your
annual QC cost of running two levels of
external control every day of patient
testing versus the predicted annual cost
of just running controls per month on
your number of instruments you could
actually calculate a cost avoidance
number and that really is something you
can take to your administration and say
by performing an IQ CP I've actually
saved money or avoided cost for the
laboratory the second thing is it
provides evidence-based quality
assurance by looking at your historical
data you're actually taking a step back
and looking at what are the risks
specific to your lab and your test
system and do you have a quality plan in
place that effectively identifies those
risks so in conclusion we've talked
about how we take the risk assessment to
identify what can go wrong design a
quality control plan as a way to prevent
or detect errors use that quality
control plan to then do a quality
assessment to see is the quality control
plan working so iqcp it gives labs
flexibility to design their QC programs
and iqcp is voluntary the goal is really
to monitor the total testing process and
it should provide a continuous cycle of
risk assessment measurement and review
and with that I believe we will take
some questions
Thank You dr. Stephen cotton for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A they do have a question you'd like
to ask dr. cotton please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type the question into the box that
appears on your screen and click send
will answer as many questions that we
have time for now let's get started
dr. cotton our first question is what
documentation needs to be signed at the
night qcp changes that's great
so I think according to great question
so according to cap if you make a change
to the iqcp plan itself the plan does
need to be resized but you don't have to
go back and resize the risk assessment
next question has anything changed since
I see iqcp was implemented well 18 ever
be subject to iqcp so I just very
recently cap has released an updated
checklist and I did see a couple of
changes the first one was related to
commercial media through microbiology I
believe now is exempt I'm having to do
an IQ CP the second one relates to fish
as I mentioned about subspecialty
classification and I believe that cap is
actually revised their stance on whether
or not
fish testing actually needs an IQ CP and
so I would encourage you to look at your
if you are cap accredited laboratory so
look at your
revised checklist and I believe that
both fish and microbiology media have
been removed from or now exempt from
having to do dr. cotton and how do you
address multiple instruments multiple
locations in an efficient IQ seeking
creo yeah that's that's great question
as well so at our institution we
certainly have labs that are spread out
over multiple sites we have a very large
respiratory therapy department and we
also have testing that's performed at
different CLIA sites and so what we have
found most efficient is actually having
one site do the majority of the risk
assessment and then share that with the
other sites and then the other sites
will then take the risk assessment and
then insert their own historical data as
well as location specific risk to really
create an individualized risk assessment
and we really feel like that by having
each site look at their own historical
data it is actually a really good way to
to catch to develop a very smart quality
control plan that really does a good job
at catching errors it is certainly a
little more work but it is you do avoid
reinventing the wheel completely because
if one site kind of takes the lead to
design the risk assessment to sort of
take a deep dive into that particular
test system and then the other sites can
then go back and say okay well I didn't
really think about that but let me add
on my specific location risks or mine
specific issues related to testing at my
site it does actually save save you some
some
time certainly and we found that for IQ
CPS that we have very similar testing
across the healthcare system the
majority of the time the quality control
plans are actually very similar so we
are able to sort of take this a single
design individualize its some for the
risk assessment but then the quality
control plan tends to be the same they
have great questions coming in but we're
almost out of time this will have to be
our last doctor cotton what is required
as part of the annual evaluation or iqcp
sure sure so as I mentioned before that
the laboratory director does have to
resign the quality control plan annually
it's also really important if you do
make a change as the first question
hinted at that you do reevaluate your
your quality control plan and obviously
if you do change test systems within
that particular year whether you're
swapping out kits from a different
vendor then you would actually need to
do redo the risk assessment if you're
actually changing vendor platform or a
manufacturer
I would like to once again thank dr.
Stephen cotton where's presentation dr.
cotton do you have any final comments
for our audience I would just say that
iqcp once you've got one under your
belts it's really not that scary as long
as you sit down with everyone and maybe
work through a template that that that
can be adopted by your lab iqcp should
be a friend thank you once again dr.
cotton before we go and let's let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing in
February 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know when
they're split cows will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
thank you for joining us and hope to see
you again soon goodbye